This Notebook LM trick is insane. Google
just dropped something wild and nobody
is talking about it. They gave Notebook
LM the power to turn your notes into
full cinematic videos, not slides, not
bullet points, actual animated mini
movies. And I tested it. What I found
blew my mind. Let me show you
everything. So, here's the deal.
Notebook LM used to be cool. You could
upload your files, get summaries, make
audio overviews. Nice stuff. But now
Google went and turned it into something
completely different. They added what
they call cinematic video overviews. And
trust me, the name doesn't even do it
justice. Let me break it down real
simple. You take your research, your
notes, your documents, you throw them
into Notebook LM, and it spits out a
fully animated video with narration,
with storytelling, with visuals that
move and flow like someone actually
edited the thing. This is not some janky
slideshow. This is real deal content.
Now, how does it actually work? Google
is running three AI models at the same
time behind the scenes. You've got
Gemini 3 acting like the creative
director. It writes the script and
builds the structure. Then you've got
Veo3 handling all the visual generation
and animation. And Nano Banana Pro ties
it all together. Three models working as
a team. That's why the output looks so
polished. Hey, if we haven't met
already, I'm the digital avatar of
Julian Goldie, CEO of SEO agency Goldie
Agency. Whilst he's helping clients get
more leads and customers, I'm here to
help you get the latest AI updates. Let
me give you a real example. Say you're
building content for something like the
AI profit boardroom. You could upload a
document that explains what the
community offers, the AI automation
workshops, the weekly calls, the
step-by-step systems. You drop that into
Notebook LM, hit create cinematic video
overview, and boom, you've got a video
that walks through the value of AI
automation for business owners. It looks
professional. It sounds professional and
you didn't edit a single frame. Think
about that for a second. You used to
need a video editor, a script writer,
and hours of work. Now you need a Google
account and 5 minutes. But wait, there's
more to this tool than just video. Let
me show you what else they added because
this is where it gets really powerful.
They built in something called deep
research. This is huge. Instead of you
going out and finding sources and
articles and data, Notebook LM does it
for you. It scans the web. It pulls in
highquality sources. It puts together a
full report with citations all inside
your notebook. So, picture this. You
want to create a video about AI
automation trends for the AI profit
boardroom community. You don't even need
to go research it yourself. You tell
Notebook LM to deep research AI
automation trends for small businesses.
It goes out, finds the best sources,
compiles everything, and then you turn
that research into a cinematic video.
The whole pipeline is inside one tool.
Now, they also expanded the file types.
you can upload. You can now throw in
Google Sheets, Word Docs, images, PDFs
from Google Drive, and even web URLs.
So, if you've got a spreadsheet tracking
results from your AI automation
workflows, you can upload that directly
and let notebook LM build content around
it. And here's another feature most
people are sleeping on, data tables. You
can now pull data from multiple sources
and Notebook LM will organize it into
clean tables. Then you can export those
to Google Sheets. So, if you're running
the AI profit boardroom and you want to
show members a comparison of different
AI tools and what they do best, you
upload your research, generate a data
table, and now you've got a clean visual
breakdown you can share or turn into
video content. They also just added
promptbased slide editing. So, if you
create a slide deck inside Notebook LM,
you can tweak individual slides just by
typing what you want changed. No
dragging stuff around, no fighting with
formatting. Just tell it what to fix and
it fixes it. And all of this runs on
Gemini 3.1 Pro now, which means the
reasoning and output quality is better
than ever. And one more thing, if you're
creating all this content with Notebook
LM, but nobody is finding it online,
you've got a traffic problem. That's
where SEO comes in. If you want more
leads, more traffic, and more sales. My
team can help you rank higher on Google.
Check the link in the comments and
description to order AI SEO online and
let us handle your back links while you
focus on growing your business. And if
you want to rank number one and get more
customers, join the SEO Elite Circle.
That's where we actually teach you how
this works. No theory, no recycled tips,
just the exact AI SEO systems we're
using right now. We break everything
down step by step with real workflows,
weekly live support, and clear actions
you can follow without guessing. If
you're serious about now, let me walk
you through exactly how I'd use this if
I were building content for the AI
profit boardroom step by step. Step one,
open Notebook LM and use discover
feature. Type in something like AI
automation strategies for online
communities. Let it pull in the best
sources from across the web. Step two,
review what Notebook LM pulls together.
It'll summarize everything, highlight
key points, and organize your sources.
Step three, hit create cinematic video
overview. Notebook LM takes all that
research and your uploads and turns it
into an animated video with narration
and structure. You can use this for
social media, for your community, for
ads, for YouTube, whatever you want.
Step four, export and share. You can
also pull out data tables, slide decks,
or audio overviews from the same
notebook. One upload multiple content
formats. That's the power here. Now, let
me be honest with you about the
limitations because I always keep it
real. Right now, cinematic video
overviews are only available if you're
on Google AI Ultra. That's their premium
plan. It's also English only for now.
You need to be 18 or older. And there's
a daily cap of about 20 videos per day.
So, it's not unlimited, but 20 videos a
day is still a lot of content. Also,
you've got extra features like
flashcards, quizzes, save chat history
with longer memory, and the ability to
create multiple audio overviews. So,
even if you don't use the video feature
right away, there's still a ton of value
in this tool. Let me give you some use
cases so you can see why this matters.
If you run a community like the AI
profit boardroom, you can create
onboarding videos from your welcome
docs. You can turn workshop notes into
sharable video recaps. You can build
explainer videos about AI automation
workflows without touching a video
editor. If you're a student, you can
turn your study notes into visual guides
that help you learn faster. If you're
building a brand, you can create product
demo videos from your feature docs. If
you're a content creator, you can go
from research to published video in
minutes instead of days. This is one of
those tools that changes how fast you
can move. And speed matters. The people
who use AI tools like this right now are
the ones who are going to be way ahead.
6 months from now. So now, here's what I
want you to do. Go try Notebook LM
today. Upload something you're working
on. Test the cinematic video feature
and then come back here and tell me what
you think. Julian Goldie reads every
comment. So, make sure you comment
below. And one more thing, if you're
creating all this content with Notebook
LM, but nobody is finding it online,
you've got a traffic problem. You can
make the best videos, the best guides,
the best content in the world, but if
nobody sees it, it doesn't matter.
That's where SEO comes in. My team at
Goldie Agency has helped hundreds of
businesses get found on Google. We build
the back links. We handle the strategy.
We do the heavy lifting so you don't
have to. If you want more leads, more
traffic, and more sales, check the link
in the comments and description to order
AI SEO online. Let us handle your
rankings while you focus on growing your
business. Seriously, stop leaving
traffic on the table. And if you want to
rank number one and get more customers,
join the SEO Elite Circle. This isn't
some generic course full of stuff you've
already heard. This is where we actually
teach you how this works. The exact AI
SEO systems we're using right now inside
our agency. We break everything down
step by step with real workflows you can
copy. We do weekly live support calls
where you can ask us anything. And we
give you clear actions to follow so
you're never sitting there guessing what
to do next. No theory, no recycled tips,
no fluff, just real systems that work.
If you're serious about scaling with SEO
and AI, this is where you start. Hit the
link in the description and join the SEO
elite circle today. I'll see you on the
inside. I'll see you in the next one.